[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is also the host of our
podcast that's very popular on ramsey
networks the fine print where he uh
helps you read the fine print on these
companies and ideas that are screwing
you over
which is what happens if you don't read
the fine print thus the name so check it
out and also of course entre leadership
podcast which i listened to this morning
george it was really really good oh
thank you very good stuff so uh check it
out that's all for business and small
business and george is the host of that
we have wonderful world-class guests on
there talking about leadership and
business this is the ramsey show where
we help people build wealth
do work that they love
and create actual
amazing relationships open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five the call is free and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it triple eight eight two five
five two two five lillian starts off
this hour in san antonio hi lillian how
are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call i
have a question about my husband passed
away this march and
i received life insurance today
um thank god he worked for a company
that really took care of us but i need
to know if we're going to be okay i do
have five children for pretty much adult
i have one fifteen-year-old son at home
um
so
um the life insurance is 954 000. he has
a pension
of about 280 and so they you know they
want to know do i want to defer this
pension or do i want to
take you know payment monthly
it will continue to grow at six percent
until retirement um so i'm not really
sure you guys have
about 300 000 in retirement um
and so i don't really know what to do i
still my home is worth about 700 000 but
i owe 330 on it so
i want your opinion on what to do
okay
i'm sorry hun
how old was he
he was only 54. oh just a pup yeah how
long were y'all married
31 years
we have uh we're about to have our
eighth grandchild
so yeah what happened
he had a heart attack oh my i'm so sorry
yeah
thank you
um
okay uh
rule number one and then we'll back
around and work around that rule
okay
um
sharon and i are getting ready to
celebrate 40
uh in in about a month
and um
uh if uh we have planned for me to die
first because if she dies first i'm not
gonna be able to handle it
[Laughter]
so
i because i won't be able to breathe and
that's where you are right now you can't
even get a full breath uh because it's
just you know
you're saying for a few minutes and then
another wave hits you and then you're
insane for a little while and that's
called grief and that makes you a normal
human
and because your heart's broken because
i mean this is like
your best friend for 30 years so um
so the rule is try to make as few big
decisions
as you can until your brain clears a
little bit
okay i do this for a living and my plan
is when in the middle of a major
tragedy
uh major grief situation i'm going to
try not to make big decisions in the
middle of that because our critical
thinking skills are just messed up by
the fog of pain
does that make sense
yes
so all of that to say i try to avoid
just you know now sometimes people have
to you know because like they don't you
the good news is you got you know uh
well over a million dollars access and
so you're fine you're gonna be okay
um and then let's just start talking
through kind of what your plan is and
what you're thinking now and then let's
see how much of it we can put the brakes
on
and because if you can do nothing for
six months and just cry
that'd be like a normal human reaction
right and you make better decisions six
months from today than you would today
does is do you agree with that
i agree yeah okay all right so let's
just back into it from there george um
now the pension
they're uh offering you a lump sum of
280.
they're offering uh
like payments monthly um
and if either that or
i'm gonna wait until retirement and
it'll continue to grow for six at six
percent
oh okay but they're not offering you a
lump sum
no they're not the 280 000 you don't
have access to
no okay
all right well here's the rule on that
it's going to die when you die
it actually won't it's it will go to my
children so
that's that's the great part so
um
that's the great part of that how much
of the month what's the monthly they're
offering you today um 1800. okay and are
you do you do you work outside the home
very little okay
all right so we need to create an income
for you to live on agreed
you're right i agree what does he what
did he make
uh about 120. okay
all right
so 1800 is 20 000 bucks a year so we're
100 000 short
right okay
right so i'm taking the i'm taking the
monthly i'll go ahead and tell you that
uh because accruing at six percent's not
exciting to me uh because you can invest
in good mutual funds and do considerably
better than that
so even if you didn't use the money i
would take it and dump it into mutual
funds
okay because i'm moving it from 6 to 10
or 12 at that point so we're going to do
that one
um
do you know your household expenses
monthly right now lillian
um they're probably at about 3 800. okay
so about let's call it 50 grand a year
you need to live how old are you right
i'm 51.
okay the 950 000 is was life insurance
money correct okay all right well his
300 000 in retirement you need to just
leave a loan
uh you will be uh are you the
beneficiary on that
yes yeah
okay you're going to be required to draw
down on that at a 10-year rate
so
um
well no i don't know spouses i don't
know spouse is on an inherited if spouse
is exempted or not some of them are
they're different do you know the terms
of it no they're not different it's
either it's either 10-year drawdown or
the spouse has an exemption one or two
i'll have to look that up in my cheat
sheet notes
um but either way um so for taking the
life insurance dave are we saying to
invest this to create the income for her
or she's gonna need part of it
temporarily
in order to create an income to live on
do you think you're gonna keep the house
so i wanted to keep it for at least
three years until my son graduates high
school okay um
the market here is crazy i can't buy
anything for 300 000 in my area right
okay um
okay there's two options we can go with
the 950
all right
um you can either invest it all and keep
the mortgage in place
which is trying to not make big
decisions okay
or you can pay off the mortgage invest
600.
either way you sit down with a smart
investor pro in your area
and uh sit down and they'll help guide
you through that
and they can answer the question on how
fast you've got to draw down
that retirement because i'm i'm
conflicted here i can't remember what it
is i gotta look it up the break it's
killing me but uh they changed the law
about 18 months ago and i've forgotten
it i've forgotten what they changed it
to
but um yeah i i
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so sorry
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five okay time to nerd out for a minute
on financial stuff for you nerds because
it's driving me nuts so i did look it up
on my cheat sheet and actually looked it
up to make sure and all that stuff so
the secure act
was passed
in the beginning of 2020 january of 2020
right before pandemic hit all right
and the secure act was basically a
method of the federal government making
you less secure and them more secure
because the idea was simply this the
you do not have to draw down on your
traditional iras or 401ks until it used
to be 70 and a half it's now 72 and a
half
okay
and that was pissing them off they don't
like that because they want to tax money
now
because they're like that's how they are
okay so
they they change the law
and it says and that was true on an
inherited ira so i could name my
daughter
or son or both
on my 401k as a beneficiary it would
roll to them in an inherited ira and
then they didn't have to draw it off and
so what happened is you could just roll
it and never get drawn on it would just
build up if you never use the money but
if you use the money there's no penalty
but there's taxes on it if you draw it
off draw an inherited ira off early okay
so it's taxed at your rate personally if
you your dad left you an ira or 401k
then you use the money you get tax on it
but there's no penalty but you didn't
have to draw it now according to secure
act you have to draw it down in 10 years
so 300 case 30 grand a year
and they get their taxes one tenth for
30 years that was the 10-year thing we
were referring to with that last caller
so she inherited as a spouse her
husband's 401k which was 300 000
and what i was trying to remember was i
thought there was a spousal exception
and there is i was right okay so she
does not have to draw it down in 10
years because she's a spouse if it was
left to the kids they would have spouse
does not have to draw it down until the
spouse hits
72 and a half and then they have what's
called rmd required minimum
distributions
so that you begin to draw down your ira
and they get their freaking taxes so
probably more information than any of
you really wanted but i just i wanted to
act like i actually thought i knew
something good i sort of knew it and i
didn't know it and
well such is life on live radio the
cheat sheet came in handy well we just
we try to when we don't know just like
be real and say i don't know
and then but i kind of knew but i wasn't
sure you had a feeling
oh there we go meaning i had read it and
retained it but i couldn't recall it oh
there you go all right open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five uh elia is with us or il ilya ilya
is with us i'm going to try and mess
that up in chicago is it ilya
yes sir you got it right thank you thank
you it took me about three tries how can
i help
um yeah so i have a question basically
kind of of what you guys would do in my
situation um i just got a brand new job
literally starting second week right now
good for you my wife thank you my wife
and i um have two cars a 2011 camry with
a 123 000 miles that we own outright and
a 2020 rashford that we currently lease
it's a three year lease we're halfway
through it right now
um and with this new job i get a company
car oh um i'm just trying to figure out
that i can use for personal use as well
so i'm just trying to figure out like
what is the best course of action i know
the car market is crazy right now so i
can probably sell the camry for the most
i
can like ever get for it um
and
if i can i don't even know if it's
possible to get out of the lease like
how do i go about that and is that even
possible every money
yes
liquid
cash we have about 25 dollars okay good
well you can just pay off the the rev
uh you're buying the lease out early and
you're you know at the end of the lease
closed in lease there's a buyout amount
right
yeah i'm out you can buy the car for
it's that plus some of your lease
payment
is what it'll be you can call them for
an early buyout number which is like a
payoff on a loan
okay yeah that's gonna and you've got
enough you've got enough money to pay it
off
okay pay you're getting how much other
debt have you got
so yeah that's the thing we have about
uh 15 000 in student loans that
the reason we haven't paid it off yet is
because we just got married in december
and i
was like in the job market and i finally
got this job and we were waiting until i
like started and
now we're trying to get everything
aligned now cool
okay well i wouldn't sell the camry
because it's not gonna free up a payment
and then you're gonna have to turn
around and go get another car on top of
that but i like getting rid of the lease
well they got a company car though they
only need one car i only need one car
for the whole family he's got he's got a
company car and then either keep the rav
or keep the camry yeah so i was gonna
say keep the rav and pay it off yeah and
then sell the camry yeah show the camry
and and then let's throw the rest of the
student loan yeah so you got 25 and uh
uh you said you're three years in
i don't know what's happening what's
that rav4 worth you think
oh man i don't even know i'm a pretty
penny in today's market that's for sure
how many of them that's what i was
asking
how many people 300 a month for the ride
right now
all right
let's pretend okay i'll just make up a
number let's say 15 000 buys at lease
out i'm probably not that far off okay
you with me okay so now you're on the
raft
and you got 10 000 in the bank and you
sell the camry for five you got 15 000
in the bank oh now we're gonna pay off
the student loan wait we're broke yeah
it's a good idea because you were
already broke now we just admitted it
and now you're gonna use a new job to
build up your emergency fund and you're
100 debt free am i right
yep so that's the kind of game plan i
want to execute here if i can i don't
know if you're going i don't know what
the payoff is on that rev
but uh
what i would do is pay off the rev sell
the camry pay all of it towards the
student loan but a thousand dollars and
you're on baby step two working on your
student loan what's the new job pay
uh
like household income for both of us
base is about 115
and not including side hustles and like
commission
bonuses we're about like 130 140. so at
the latest by halloween you're 100 debt
free
okay
you see how we're doing this okay
yeah absolutely no screwing around and i
don't want to hear about going on some
vacation while you've got a student loan
staring you in the face
yes sir you just went to work so by god
go to work
yes sir i hear you
that rav4 is worth about 35-40 grand by
the way okay all right but yeah that's a
lot of pretty pennies yeah so um i
wonder if
i i don't think he tells the net he gave
you the year it was 20 20. okay
so it's pretty new it's just 22.
it's not going to be a 15 payoff then
it's going to be a 20
20 22 somewhere in there probably to buy
that lease out so he's halfway through a
three-year lease
yeah so um
the buyout and the lease had to do with
old used car numbers before the market
went nuts so
could sell it um and make a profit at
this point he's not they're making the
money just clean this mess up by
halloween either way yeah so get her get
her done if you like the rav4 keep the
rav4 yeah well i mean you like the rav4
and better than a 2011 camry yeah
i think they'll run forever it's only
got 120 000 miles i mean i'm not it's
not a bad hooptie but it's a hoop deal
okay if you're going to choose he's
making 110 he's cleaning up his mess he
doesn't have to they don't have to
because if the if they get rid of it
they're driving a hooptie you know
what's going to happen this time next
year they're buying another car yeah for
cash anyway they started might as well
just keep the good car and work your way
through it yeah that's the way i'm
looking at but i mean you can argue with
me if you want i'm not going to dare to
do that not here we'll do that off air
why not because i can't win dave it's
not fun for me come on george
of course it's fun and of course you
could win we'll let you win sometimes
thank you but if you let me win did i
really win that's the question
the thing with these car leases dave a
lot of people are probably in one and
thinking should i get out how do you
know the right way to get out of a lease
is it always early but you know and save
up the cash the car lease is the worst
buy
in all of automotive
and here's why
when you put in the value of the car and
you look at what you're paying on it
your cost of capital on average and car
fleece is 14.2 percent wow so you're
borrowing money at 14 interest they
don't disclose that it's interest
because it's not technically interest
you're technically renting the car so
there's no truth in lending law because
there's not technically any lending
point being real good time to get out of
a car is now
if you can get rid of that lease by
selling that puppy in this up market
that'd be a real good plan because
you're getting fleeced in your lease
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
well it's event week you guys orlando i
hope you're ready
because i'll tell you a couple weeks ago
vegas they brought the house down
and orlando we got 26 tickets left so we
got over 3 000 folks coming going to be
a sellout easily here in the next hour
or so
you know jump in and get your tickets
quick rachel cruz george campbell my
co-host today and i will be doing the
event with dr john dalone and ken
coleman they will be hosting a free
bonus session john again will uh about
work and relationships uh before we kick
off the main sessions and then george
and rachel and i will be there along
with those guys as
the event ends on thursday evening may
the 19th a couple days from now uh we'll
be signing books and uh taking photos
and all that kind of good stuff after
the event and so uh yeah come on out
guys it's gonna be great human beings
should be around other human beings
that was my favorite part was just
shaking hands and meeting people hearing
their stories it just gave me fuel in
the tank well and i'm just i you know
i'm like
because people were like well never
shake hands again
there's a new normal well by god i am i
might even i might even hug you so be
careful wow you know
it's just unbelievable i'm not signing
up for that i can't make that promise
quite yet we'll start with the handshake
we'll take it from there we'll see how
things go
but it's a fun event we had a great time
in vegas and if you're in the orlando
area or even it's worth the flight
people have been traveling from all over
the country to journalists i mean the
vegas uh you know had a whole bunch of
californians there of course
you know uh los angeles thinks las vegas
is a suburb so
uh but anyway it sort of is i mean it's
right there but anyway thanks for coming
guys and orlando thank you for your
turnout uh again there's a couple
tickets left at ramseysolutions.com
events
phoenix is half sold out for november
the first
uh or september the 13th sacramento is
three quarters sold out for november the
first minneapolis three-quarters sold
out and there's just a few hundred
tickets left for these events in the
fall already
and don't call me whining because you
can buy your tickets because i've been
telling you about it so get your tickets
we'll be in san antonio november 15th
and we would love to have you there 25
uh if you want a four pack we have uh
four packs starting as low as sixty
dollars and going up from there so check
it out guys and get your tickets as soon
as you can our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
uh and you get free samples free
shipping new promos all the time always
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
kyle in tampa
with gas being so expensive right now
i'm looking into selling my jeep and
getting a tesla my wife and i are going
way over budget on gas and it seems like
a good time to get an electric vehicle
even with the car market the way it is
she thinks it's a bad idea to finance a
car but i think it'll save us money in
the long run who wins the argument
oh dave loves this question i can see
the fumes coming out of your head right
now there's just so many things wrong
about his decision hey it's a tesla
uh be their payment dave i gotta see you
thought it was gonna be cheaper because
you have to pay the light bill bubba to
plug in your little car this is true i
got a comment yesterday on instagram a
guy said i don't trust a man who drives
an electric vehicle whoa
that's that's new for me
now i understand respect but trust i'm
untrustworthy because my car doesn't
have an engine like yours dave oh but
that's besides the point just now just
venting i mean you and rachel both both
of you are driving these batteries now i
mean it's and you're paying for our gas
thanks to the chargers out front now
that just pisses me off because the
people that work here that drive
gasoline vehicles don't get free fuel so
why is it that the landlord is obligated
to put out a little plugging station i
didn't decide that you did
well i some block codes or something
like
like i don't know or maybe maybe my
maybe uh wait
i know what it was
rachel's husband built the building this
is a conspiracy he's in cahoots he's in
cahoots he put those plugs out there so
he could end up cause he knew she was
gonna end up buying one of those dadgum
things winston if you're listening be on
the wall that's what it is your
father-in-law is mad that's what it is
now i figured it out i see their scheme
well back to kyle's question here's the
thing i took a question like this
similarly the other day okay the young
guy yeah he's single and he said well
i'm in canada
the petrol is very expensive i'm just
going to go finance a 60 000 tesla to
save money
because that makes sense when you say
that coming out of your mouth does that
not does that not blow your brains out i
mean it hurts my brain
so i'm gonna go finance 60 000 to save
money how do you calculate the roi the
break-even on a situation like this
obviously the financing aside how do you
know what you actually pay
to fill up the stupid thing do you know
i i've done the math on oh is it okay
yeah at home it's cheaper now if you're
charging out in public it's a little
more expensive but it's you know it's
like 13 cents a kilowatt and so you
multiply that by how many kilowatts okay
so what does it take to that's a car for
a week
for a week uh depending on your driving
i know but i mean you're driving back
and forth to work here
i would say about maybe
10 15 20 bucks
for me so it's substantially less than
my gas yes my gas might be 30 bucks in
that same period of time i mean we live
about the same distance from that yes so
we don't neither one of us drive that
far okay so if that was the case so
you're saving
20 bucks
how long does it say take to get sixty
thousand dollars saving 20 bucks many
many years
maybe a retirement longer than you're
going to live okay oh my god that's
stupid
so the excuse of i'm doing it to save on
gas that just doesn't cut it well you
are saving on gas but you're not saving
on money
well to them it's the same thing at this
point it's not part of the friend i mean
because you know it's the same thing
when i first started teaching this stuff
a thousand years ago i had a guy in the
financial peace university class and he
drove one mile to work he was an
18-wheeler driver he drove over the road
so he would drive one mile to work park
his truck get into the 18-wheeler drive
for a week over the road come home get
back in his pickup and drive one mile
home wow he had an awesome
perfect cherry little
1978 pickup it was a kind of a classic
it was beautiful perfect there wasn't a
thing on the thing
comes and goes sold my truck
going why'd you sell your truck he goes
i wanted a new one
gas mileage was killing me
dude you dropped two miles a week the
gas mileage can't kill you how are you
gonna you're gonna break even on that
new one by driving it to the moon and
back maybe oh my gosh wow the break-even
analysis is what it's called people and
how long does it take you for to get
your money back with the money saved
that's a break-even analysis and the
point is it's going to take longer than
you live no you don't finance a tesla to
save money that's dumber than a rock
this happens a lot in the solar world
this you get these all the time with
solar panels it's the same idea
hey dave we're going to get solar panels
to save on electricity it's not going to
cost 50 000 to finance them
yeah but they don't cost 50 000 anymore
but uh
but i mean
they actually do have about a seven year
break even if you're in an expensive
if you're in a good sun area and an
expensive electric market and you pay
cash for them and you pay cash for them
they got about a six or seven year break
even which makes them yeah okay
but you're not gonna break even on tesla
while you're alive okay
so
and you're a tesla driver keep that in
mind yeah
here we go let's not make it personal
come on george here's my question
anytime someone says well you and rachel
you and rachel i'm just i'm i'm
here well what do you guys say he
doesn't trust a guy that drives a bag he
doesn't trust a guy who doesn't have a
car with an engine in it that's his
that's his vibe hmm so it sounds like i
had cars in the backyard up on blocks
that didn't have an engine in it
i don't know that i trust you at least
not with my car
oh man
that's cold i mean i like making funny
all but they're actually very cool cars
they're really fast they are and they're
just they're they scare me because
they're too quiet oh so
there's fear days that's it it's a
latent fear
i think it's which fear is coming out as
anger how is the car moving without
witchcraft it's witchcraft that's what
it is my mom felt the same way about
harry potter when it came out yeah well
she was right about that too but the uh
uh yeah
yeah but the
uh now i drove on things and it's
because all of a sudden you're going 60
and you don't even know it because
there's nothing telling it's just a
g-force there's no other than your
brains are flying out the back of your
head oh my gosh
and it's just um
i mean because i'm used to like hearing
a muffler when i'm going fast or
something kick in right i want to i want
to hear there's there's audio feedback
that says to your brain you are now
going fast the louder it is the better
that's the when there's no audio telling
you or you are now going fast it scared
the crap out of me because i was like
dead gum i'm in a neighborhood here i'm
about to break the
uh sound barrier or something right here
in the neighborhood well don't be scared
dave i'm i'm yeah i'm i'm you're safe
with me and rachel i'm so it's not that
i don't trust you people it's i'm scared
of you
thank you for admitting it really now
what it comes down to i'm scared of you
george it took me one of your life goals
has now been accomplished
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right to wrap up all that carrying
on
whether it's electric or whether it's
gas you cannot afford to buy more
expensive car to save
on the fuel
it all the breakeven analysis almost
never works because the car is so much
more expensive than the fuel so you're
moving from a 3 000 or 5 000 or 10 000
car to a 30 or a 50 or 60 000 car that
spread you're not going to recoup it in
fuel savings of any kind electric or gas
period and you're certainly not going to
be able to justify the payment under any
freaking circumstance so just don't do
it there's very very few exceptions to
that rule now if you're driving a
eight thousand dollar pickup that gets
four miles to the gallon and you trade
it for an eight thousand dollar honda
accord
yeah because you didn't spend any more
money and you don't have payments then
you would save money on your gas
bill but but what happens is is that the
human brain
melts down
and says to you you're allowed to buy a
newer car with payments and that tells
you that your brain is not working okay
it's amazing how our brains can justify
those terrible decisions because we go
well on paper i mean i'm going to save a
lot of money yeah i'll help you with the
paper emily is in st louis hi emily how
are you
i'm great how are you better than we
deserve how can we help
well first i wanted to say you don't get
enough credit for your amazing comedic
timing so if you get to get this whole
radio thing you could always do stand up
instead oh bless your heart i'm here for
that netflix special
[Laughter]
how can we help
so i'm about to jump up in rent from
900
to almost double that at 1600 a month
and i just wanted to make sure i'm not
making a big mistake because um i do
have a relatively low income
i net about
2500
a month
um but so the reason why i
do think that
it might be okay for me to do that is i
am very fortunate to have a trust fund
and i do draw
700 a month from that and then it is
always just there in the background
i i try not to even think about that it
exists because i want to save that for
my retirement
but it is there
what do you do for a living
um well luckily it's george today
instead of john because i'm in doggy
daycare i heard you guys arguing about
that recently
okay you oh you do doggy daycare yeah
yeah i'm not here
i missed that discussion okay i can only
imagine okay uh and but you're not
making much money
correct so what is your long-term career
plan
well um so i'm 34 and for a long time i
really didn't have a career plan
because i had a very difficult
multi-year
struggle with crippling anxiety and
depression
and it got started turning around when i
actually
started working in doggy daycare it
changed my entire life
and now i'm like when i used to be
miserable it was really hard for me to
get out of bed in the morning
and now i'm just like one of the
happiest people i know i have the
pandemic um
actually
i'm i'm an introvert and
it's kind of i feel bad saying that the
pandemic
really was great for my mental health
because i
like had this three month period where i
just got as much
alone time as i needed without
neglecting my friends or family or my
job
and but it really just started me on
this big upward trajectory of healing
and um
so now i am
i do feel like maybe i could
without jeopardizing my mental health
start looking in other directions
um
unfortunately the other direction i want
to look in is the screenwriting that my
degree is in film
obviously that
i think you can start that now
i think you can start that now while
you're doing this and i think you need
to start i actually have um
i think you need to start doing some
freelance writing also to start making
some extra money right now
because honey you know i really love the
doggy daycare has helped with your
anxiety i love all that i think that's
fun
and i like that part of your story uh
what i don't like is that you're trading
it for another kind of anxiety called
financial anxiety because you don't make
any money
and um you cannot do rent that is 50
of your income
and and prosper right you're not going
to prosper
so no the hundred 1600 rent with a
thirty two hundred dollar income
including your trust money
uh that's fifty percent of your income
you're gonna struggle
and um and and i you know so
i i would stay with the 900 for a while
um and
so i've been at the
900 for four years actually and it's a
teeny tiny apartment
um about 275 square feet doesn't matter
you can't afford it
doesn't matter
you can't afford to go to 50
it's just you know it's like okay uh you
know i'm driving an old car
but i i and i'd really like a brand new
uh car well you can't afford it you
don't have any money
you know and so that's kind of where
this is and it's cold but it's a math
thing it's not a an emotion thing now
what i do want you to do is i do want
you to have some hope to move into a
better place but that hope is tied to
changing your income that's why i was
asking you those other questions yeah
the thing emily i want you to think
about is your long-term future not just
what's going to happen next year but the
next 10 years where do i want to be do i
want to be a homeowner because rent's
going to keep going up
and so when you think about it that way
50 of your take-home pay being eaten up
by your rent means you're not going to
be able to save up for that down payment
you're not going to be able to invest 15
and retire with dignity so i want you to
think longer term and make decisions
based on that so the good news is is
there are plenty of ways for folks that
are introverts to make a lot of money it
does not require that you put yourself
in a highly
uh in a crowded room
you know every day all day to make a
living i i wouldn't recommend that i'm
not proposing that to you but i do want
you to say okay what can i do that gives
me the same kind of peace
that what i'm currently doing
does
and makes three times more
and i don't know what that is exactly
it could be it could be in the writing
area it could be
the good news is that you can do a lot
of writing now from home and uh and then
you move up into a little better place
and then you start saving for a house
but we got to get your income up long
term or you're going to be trading one
kind of anxiety for another that's
what's going to end up happening and no
i cannot i'm going to beg you not to do
the sixteen hundred dollars in rent
until you do something to change your
income hold on we're going to have the
team pick up and send you a copy of ken
coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
and also the career assessment as well
the career assessment uh and that'll
help you maybe determine some ideas of
some things you could work on that would
be
beneficial
the good news in our current world
george is that
there's so many jobs available
there's such a shortage of labor in
almost every area
that she can probably find something
that is not a high stress
you know high anxiety situation every
headline is there's a shortage of pizza
delivery drivers now yeah and so you can
go make really good money 25 bucks an
hour delivering pizzas she can actually
make more than she's making now doing
that um and this doesn't have to be
forever people think well i don't want
to do that well i'm asking you to do it
for a year to clean your financial mess
up yeah and there's a i mean we saw an
article come out yesterday every pizza
hut dominoes
um
they're all uh they're seeing drop in
sales
and and their revenues are down not
because people don't want pizzas but
because they don't have any drivers to
deliver them and when delivery is down
sales are down and so all of them stock
is hurting
and they're because their profits are
down because they're not delivering
pizzas they can't get drivers and so
there is a shortage and so this is you
know what biden bucks did when you pay
people not to work people here's how
this works when you pay people not to
work guess what they do they don't work
they don't work
how's that what's called cause and
effect
that's scientific yeah
see economics
economics it's a it's a tricky little
business this econ thing
uh
yeah pay people not to work and
then they won't work
create a shortage of anything and the
price goes up supply and demand people
so guess what your inflation is caused
by
labor cost gone through the roof
you can't get people to work
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king in the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones as we take it all about your
building wealth about doing work that
you love and about creating actual
amazing relationships the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money sergey is with us to
start off this hour in new york hi
sergey what's up
hey how are you dave great man how can i
help
uh got a question for you about the
selling the house we've
never done it before uh we purchased the
house
now we are looking to purchase another
house planning on and
obviously question came up to sell our
house that we have right now
and uh
there's uh when we go through realtor
there's seven percent
we have to pay for selling our house
uh and since you know
i'm starting to started to listen to the
show and working on
uh eliminating our own depth and we've
done it uh we finished the step two
uh so now we i always constantly me and
my wife we're always saying about you
know everything reasonably when we plan
things and everything
so now we plan about this and
there's seven percent that bugs me i
don't have peace in my heart
to sell the house you're right you're
out of toothache
have you ever had a toothache
yes i did before absolutely
did you use pliers or a dentist
dentist okay there's some things you
don't do yourself because you don't know
what you're doing you told me you didn't
know what you're doing
right right yeah i've had friends this
is your most expensive asset
it's a hundreds of you when you make a
mistake selling a piece of real estate
it ain't ten dollars dude
i mean when you make a mistakes on pizza
real estate it's tens of thousands of
dollars and you're in a whack-a-doodle
world right now for real estate it's
cray-cray out there the list ain't
amateur hour man
you definitely want a pro in your corner
it's gonna save you more than seven
percent oh and by the way let me help
you with this it's not seven percent
it's three and a half because some duber
realtor will bring you an offer if
you'll agree to pay them for their
buyers portion of three and a half and
you're only going to end up saving the
seller's portion which is three and a
half and
and now we're really down into you're
going to lose it a monkey can sell a
house right now but will they sell it
for the right price and without a bunch
of errors that cost you tens of
thousands of dollars
i wouldn't sell my own house right now
and i've had a real estate license since
i was 19 so since 1978
you're gonna make more
and you're gonna have a lot less hassle
and you know i i just i i don't even
work on my own cars anymore i don't know
i used to open the hood and get a 9 16
and adjust the i could watch this on
youtube and fix it myself well i mean
there wasn't youtube then but i mean i
could set the timing on the monte carlo
350 right i mean i i could do all that i
open the hood now and it looks like a
freaking spaceship under there i can't
even touch that stuff i don't fix every
time i try to fix my car now it costs me
more than it would have cost me to have
somebody fix my car because i break
something and that's what you're gonna
do sergey don't do it yeah i've i've had
a family member who did for sale by
owner and it was the worst nightmare and
i had tried to warn them to stay away
from that but there are such costly
mistakes you make you're not reaching
the bigger market because realtors have
access to the mls they take better
photos they understand strategy and
staging and what is going to cause
someone to pay more money and so in the
long run you're going to make more on
that purchase by going through a realtor
well and here's the thing okay let's
pretend you get one of these houses that
people are going bananas okay where you
get like 60 offers or 40 offers or
something
the seller it's almost impossible
emotionally for the seller to manage
that process
and and clean through that and get the
best possible deal and deal
professionally with the other 39 who
don't get the house
i mean you've got to have some
communication lines open you have to
have a process basically you're
conducting a freaking auction
in a lot of these situations and you've
got to know how to manage that
logistically and and what the law says
about it you'll get yourself in a pinch
man i wouldn't do it i mean you can do
what you want to do but i think you're
getting a bargain at seven percent
uh if you get a good real estate agent
now i mean if you've got uncle charlie
who got his license three weeks ago and
he wants you to do it because he's
family no charlie's dumb as you are
don't do it
that you know he doesn't know what he's
doing either no you get a high-octane
high-quality real estate agent that
knows what they're doing does a couple
of hundred transactions a year when they
step in i mean you're not you're never
going to feel the tooth when it comes
out
that's true and everyone who's worked
with one of those amazing realtors goes
that was worth every single penny i paid
them
get a good one you get a bad one it's
like anything else but i mean i and it's
the same thing i mean i don't i don't do
my own taxes i don't do i don't write my
own will
i don't work on my own car and i don't
pull my own teeth
you know it's it's there's some things
and you've got all your teeth that tells
me yeah that's done well this was
working out but the the diy thing
um i mean there's some things you feel
that way about and you're wrong and this
is one of them it's the actual
normal market data and i can't really
talk about it in this market but the
normal market data is that a realtor
sold house with a high quality real
estate agent will sell for more than
seven percent more than the non-real
estate agent sold house that's normal in
this world who the crud knows i mean
because you don't even know what they're
going to sell for an asking price is now
suggesting starting point
you know it doesn't mean anything
anymore asking price used to be
suggested starting point i'm going to
offer less you offer less you're not
getting the house you forget it now in
most of these markets that's where we
and you're relying on a sign in the yard
and then uploading to whatever site will
allow you to upload your iphone photos
that were crappily taken and so when you
work with a realtor they know the
professional photographers they
understand how to stage it they
understand how to market it well they
understand every strategy around
contingencies and this is the kind of
market we're in
you're hiring a
marketing professional
for
seven percent
i mean and if you were doing something
else that was a seven hundred thousand
dollar transaction
and it was a complicated transaction you
wouldn't think anything about paying the
attorney that did the transaction or
whoever whatever you it's part of the
process and a complicated thing and i
just highly recommend it all the data
that's out there in a normal market says
that you're worth that they're worth it
um in this market they're probably more
than worth it and those of you thinking
about buying a house same deal
get you a good buyer's agent
because i mean if you go on
ramseysolutions.com and click on elp for
real estate endorsed local provider
ramsey trusted real estate agents that
we trust
they're all high octane we've vetted all
of them we know what they know what
they're doing we you know and if you're
going to buy a house in this world
you've got to
you know you got to get some advice like
you have somebody go no those people are
going crazy walk away from that deal
it's a bad deal yeah you get too
emotional when it's just you yeah and
you get bought in on this one house and
you start to make stupid decisions yeah
good agent makes all the difference and
when you're dealing you know
man
it's it's it's definitely not amateur
hour right now
i would feel better about you being a
fsbo and i think you'd have less damage
in a normal world but right now good
gracious absolutely not this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today i've laughed over the
years of how many people have tried to
call me an overnight success you work
your butt off for 30 years and now
you're an overnight success
on the surface it makes for a much more
exciting story but i know that overnight
success is not really what happens
uh it it you really have to
you know
you have to create momentum you have to
create meaning and a few years ago we
developed a thinking way of thinking
around here at ramsey we call it the
momentum theorem and some math formula
focused intensity f i
over t over time f i over t multiplied
by large g god
focused intensity over time multiplied
by god equals unstoppable momentum and
we've taught this lesson in detail on
how to create focused
intensity
over time multiplied by god to create
unstoppable momentum to leadership
all over america i teach this to our
team i've taught it in entre leadership
for years
and
the team decided that it's a great idea
to turn it into a one of our little
ramsey quick reads
the only problem george is
it's not much that's my kind of book
it's like it's 60 pages no it's no you
wish 43 pages it's a pamphlet
it's not even a book
it's just it's it's so thin i mean we
can make a paper airplane out of it but
it's 10 bucks is all that's the good
news and you'll read it in about what 20
minutes or 30 minutes speed reader but
the cool thing is um
hey
if you look back over the past year uh
what parts of your life are stuck what
needs a little mojo
what muddy trench are you slogging in
uh where do you need something to break
open like your marriage your parenting
your mental health your career your
money your business
uh guess what momentum has to do with
all of those things and momentum is not
accidental it is created
and this theory this theorem shows you
how uh so i'm going to promise you
you're going to feel like
you didn't get much for 10 bucks but
here's the other thing if you get one
idea for 10 bucks
it's probably worth ten bucks yeah and
what i love about the momentum theorems
then is that much there when you
multiply it by that big g by god that's
infinite yep and you talk about this in
the book but when you multiply something
by the infinite it's an infinite result
the answer on the other side of the
equation equation math equation is
always infinite it's a calculus thing
right so
uh to infinity and beyond right but i
mean it's infinite that's what it is so
yeah it's uh you want unstoppable
momentum this is how it works and we lay
it all out for you so that's kind of fun
i haven't done a quick read so i thought
we needed one and they thought we needed
one so
sat down and uh
typed it out and then they edited it
which was a lot harder than typing it
and um again there's just there's not
much to it but the idea and the concept
is worth a bazillion dollars and it's
what this place was built on it's
whether you're getting out of debt or
building a business this book is for all
areas of life and so i'd pick a copy up
and read it an hour check it out or less
joe's in phoenix hi joe how are you
oh i think i did something wrong did we
lose him i think joe went just as i got
to him he got tired of me hearing him
but talk he lost his momentum scott's in
atlanta hey scott how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i got a question for you uh last
last year year before my mom got
diagnosed with dementia uh i got three
older brothers and we wind up having
put her in a nursing home i'm sorry she
has uh two properties one that she lived
in on nine acres in north carolina and
then a rental property a mile up the
road that's on two acres
the rental property is not been rented
in over 15 years
needs some work done to it and it's uh
it's an area that's kind of sketchy and
not sketchy but
it's an older area but all around it
700 000 homes are going up so mom owns
the last two big swaths of land in union
county basically
and um
so i have guaranteed this state i'm
trying to figure out whether or not to
sell it or paid to have it renovated and
then sell it
i had one
had one contractor come out and look at
it and he basically said the house is
built in 83 i mean it's really dated
has some water damage
um
but he made an offer
to renovate from 130 to 150 000
but that didn't include anything
structural that we might have found
on the renovation
well
scott because well itself foreign
but then i said put the killers out
there see what happens and
one guy came back 180. he offered 184
[Music]
and she said well fixed up i could
probably get you 400 for it but that's
gonna probably take a hundred thousand
well then she brings me a contractor but
he wants 130 150
just basic rental and then throws in the
caveat that if there's structural damage
there's going to be more yeah well
i'm not i'm not doing a renovation i'm
not doing a renovation in an estate
renovations are a pain in the butt you
don't need a new hobby
well i'm not going to do it i would just
pay to go you're going to deal with all
the freaking hassle
okay
you're you're going to be dealing with a
mess you're going to be dealing with the
hassle the stress the process the delays
the increases in materials the oh there
is structural damage all this crap just
sell it as is and be done with it turn
it into money
okay and then with this market the way
it is because i used to be a millionaire
until biden got in office
you have but i'm mad i was over
over a million dollars when he came into
office i'm sitting at 800 000 now a 250
000 loss on what
on my 401k oh it hasn't gone it you're
okay it's going to be right back don't
worry about that
oh my gosh
it sounds like a money pit though yeah
yeah get get a different realtor i don't
care for the way this one's transacting
here
um
jump online at uh
at ramseysolutions.com and find one of
our elps and just put it on the market
as is where it is and sell it um it
sounds like it might be a tear down
it sounds like it might be the dirt is
what it's worth but that dirt might be
worth 300
also the way you're talking here so
but now this is not you don't need to
get the renovation business you weren't
signed up for that and she should have
so i mean how do things sit dormant for
15 years it should have been so long
time ago that's no investment yeah but
yeah i'd get rid of it and turn it into
money and then it's the money's laying
there for your mom and that's your job
is to do this on behalf of your mom
and then if she doesn't need the money
and there's it turns into an inheritance
then it's easier to split up money than
it is an old ragged house
so yeah get rid of it and you probably
need to go and get her house sold too
she's probably not coming back home
and just turn everything into money and
that's pretty cold and unemotional to
just throw that around but
i'm all i'm doing simplifying your life
because i'm telling you to do what
you're going to end up doing anyway
it's just a matter of when how do you
help people process through the
sentimental value of property and this
was mama's property
how do you navigate that you don't want
to hang on to things i think you just
have to kind of have a dr john deloney
moment and just say it out loud you know
this is sad
i mean like uh
my grandma passed away many years ago
and
uh
my uncle's aunt's parents decided they
weren't keeping that that farm it was a
small farm by then they sold off a lot
of it and subdivided it but um
the old house had been in the family
three generations
and i played in the backyard and
everybody else played in the backyard
you know and it's it's kind of sad and
when i'm in that little town i visit i
drive by
you know just have a little moment right
but uh but that didn't mean we need to
keep that house
because nobody in the family was around
to make mess with it and what was it you
know it's it's not
it was time you know it was a season and
the season's over and stuff is stuff and
but it's um
you know
big things like cars and houses and that
kind of stuff it's very difficult to
let your sentimentality uh override uh
good wisdom
and uh uh
and yet you still just have to say out
loud this sucks you got to separate the
emotion from the facts and the logic and
the financial pieces i don't know if you
separate i think you just admit it you
say it's there
even though this makes me sad it's still
the right thing to do
even though
we could get a little bit more for this
house if we put 100 000 into it it's not
worth the hassle
it's not going to change her situation
and he's the guardian doing this
representing for her so even though you
know
her
home and you start selling the stuff out
of the house you have an estate sale and
then you sell the house itself and
that's painful while she's alive and in
the nursing home she's got dementia
she's not coming home
it's sad it's just i mean you just
process you say out loud this just sucks
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host quincy and porsha are with us in
coral springs florida it says on my
screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
how you guys doing
we are amazing and so are you how much
have you paid off
73 000 dollars love it how long did this
take
three years all right and your range of
income during that time
so we were we were still dating at the
time uh we got married 2020 but we we
were dating at the time i was making six
thousand a year
uh and she made 26 000 a year this past
year we made our first hundred thousand
whoa
well i gotta tell you quincy you've
improved
quincy i was worried about you at first
but you've improved quite a bit what
were you doing for six thousand a year i
was worried about me too
but porsha still thought he thought you
were worthy so she brought you onto the
game
thank you dave i like it i like it so
what was the 73 000 in debt
uh so we had a couple credit cards
banana republic best buy uh porsche had
a car loan twelve thousand and then the
rest was student loans sixty thousand
dollars worth of student loans wow
so what do you guys do for a living
i am a choreographer and a dance studio
owner and i am a vocal director and a
contracted uh singer here in south
florida okay because i we just they just
showed your picture up on youtube and
you look like a couple of freaking
models that's what i thought two days so
i knew i knew the glamour shot that you
were somewhere in the business so
you're beautiful we have to give y'all
something nice you know yeah you guys
are beautiful man i mean it's amazing
all right
so cool very cool congratulations all
right what got you started on this whole
ramsay kick
well um our church was offering it at
church by the glades and our friends sam
and jade warshaw took us under their
wings
saw that we were dating and wanted to
fix our money and just helped us when we
were 21
and um helped us get on track and we
just started doing it
now now wait a minute who did you say
took you under the wing
sam and jade warshaw jade
same jade we know her gosh okay
and i know your church i've spoken there
they're wonderful i was there i was
there we were both there we lead worship
there so you probably oh my god
man that's some of the best worship
anywhere you guys are incredible thank
you so much it's it's it's miami vibe
man it's awesome i love it it has to be
it has to be you guys are getting it
it's great yeah so fun well i didn't
know well we've got good we've got good
common friends then so yeah so that guy
they got you they got you started
because jada lights you up now i mean
she'll light you up and get you going
right oh she they lit us up and we've
been going ever since even after the
pandemic we
we actually paid off all of our student
loans in one year um in eight months
actually
wow in 2021 so we were a bit afraid to
pay it off because every um everything
that that happened but man like they
just made sure that we understood our
goals and
we just said you know what let's just
pay it off and in eight months we paid
it off and now we're debt free i love it
i love it you guys are incredible so no
more falling for the banana republic uh
in-store credit card offer apparently
to save 10 long time ago and i worked
for a company that needed certain you
know uniforms but no more no more
absolutely not i don't even dress like
that at all
you're over it well you guys are very
impressive so what do you tell another
young couple they've got a normal life
like you had credit cards student loan
debt and they go well biden's gonna
forgive it and the credit card gives me
rewards what do you say to people like
that
as tempting as it may sound like man you
just gotta take it into your own hands
like you have the power to
to change your situation and we
we we had a big hole to shovel but we
just made our shovel bigger the best way
that we could
and here we are today yeah just take it
a step at a time so it sounds like life
was happening until it works yeah life
was just kind of happening to you and
you decided to happen to it
absolutely and we're contractors so we
don't even have like a um
steady income so we had like we really
had everything stacked up but we made a
choice and we stuck to it very cool you
guys are awesome absolutely incredible
so proud of you guys very very neat plan
is awesome and it works it works it
works it works it works it's not a magic
trick just do the work and it works yeah
so just you you just buckle down live on
nothing and get it done
and you know what what's weird is god
will provide when you start working a
plan got to provide the work
amen you got lots of work didn't you
yeah oh we got so much work that i was
like where is this coming from yeah we
didn't even submit for this
how did we get this job you know like
that's what was happening
that's very cool good for you guys well
done well done well give pastor david a
hug for me he's a great guy
yes he is we will yeah very good stuff
all right we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth how you can
too that's the next chapter in your
story without a doubt you two are on the
business for that it's good very good
stuff and a copy of total money makeover
for you to give away to someone and
we're going to give you a uh access to
financial peace university and every
dollar premium ramsey plus membership
for a year
and you can either use that yourself or
you can give it away to somebody maybe
you'll be jade to somebody else right
man that's awesome thank you guys so
much you guys are incredible very fun
talking to you good stuff and we're
proud for you all right 73 000 paid off
quincy and porsha in coral springs
florida
making uh did that in three years making
6k 26k up to 100k count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it i love their energy man
i will that place that that that is a
great church the church is full of
energy for one thing but yeah and uh
certainly jade is there's no question
about that they're good people and uh
good good stuff fun amazing you put
yourself around good people who are
wanting to grow and you all of a sudden
you know you grow you got to be careful
because you become who you hang around
with
and you know you need to be hanging
around people that are knocking stuff
down you know picking it up knocking it
down there you gotta
this sitting around waiting on somebody
else to fix your life if that's who
you're hanging around with you're gonna
have a long life well most people are
surrounded by a bunch of eeyores who are
going well little man can't get ahead
i'll always have a car payment biden's
gonna forgive it one of these days
and all of a sudden there you are and
you're eor and you entertain a clown you
join the circus and so be careful
be careful people entertain a clown and
join a circus don't do it
i don't entertain clowns that's good i
like that i mean i might actually hang
out with dave ramsey i'm trying to build
expect me to steal that line okay
because that's a really i don't think i
invented it it's you know it's public
domain oh yeah okay then i can steal it
and i'll just say and say i said it
right yeah you don't have to give me
credit it's fine i will i've stolen
enough airlines over the years
fair trade yeah
all right
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're glad you're
here
no uh
man
be not deceived evil company corrupts
good habits
you do become who you hang around with
that's why we don't let our children run
around juvenile delinquents because your
child will become a juvenile delinquent
okay if little johnny down the street's
got a trash mouth expect your kid to
come home with a trash mouth right
and don't be shocked all right your
little angel's not going to survive
this in this uh
this exposure and and guess what you
won't either and it's not to say we have
to snub somebody and be mean to somebody
i'm not ever unkind to someone i'm
talking about who your closest friends
were see that couple they had another
couple come alongside them that we
happen to know they're really sharp
and put their arms around them walk with
them you know hover over them encourage
them push them
the opposite of someone that's holding
you back and going well you know you
just you know you crazy do that and you
know you put all your money in bitcoin
and you know and all these dumb but
things that people you run around with
say and
then all of a sudden you're just another
dumb but because you run around with
them you got to create boundaries and go
hey we can i can see you once a year but
you're not going to be one of my close
people who i let into my life your
income
studies have shown over a 10-year period
of time will be within 10 to 15 percent
of the average of your 10 closest
friends
some of you are going i need some new
friends i need dave ramsey to be my
friend let's up this let's go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host alan is with us alan is in new
jersey newark to be precise hi alan how
are you
how you doing ramsay um just trying to
put this all together and i hope to see
how we can best unpack this
now i have about
me and my wife of about like 900 000 in
debt but it's not
all crazy that is investment debt so
just uh give you a run about um just
from what we make
uh my wife she's works at
the port she's a longshoreman and she
makes about 160.
i work in it field and uh the defeater
field and i make about 115. so let's put
that there
i have a nice little nest egg of about
60 grand
that's put aside and i'm 33 she's 32.
we're married with four kids that's
under 10. so who is 10 another yeah so
that's one thing
um about the the debt portion
i have about
166 000 in my primary home
i bought a house that i renovated and
you know i just renovated it as a
two-family home
and that's probably arv it's probably
worth about 400 right now i don't have
no debt on that but however
i had to take it out about a hundred
thousand to put into the property
to renovate it right so so you do have
debt on it or you don't i don't have
that with that property no i don't have
that on it but but you got a hundred
thousand unsecured
unsecured that you used on that property
okay correct i got 20
well it's less than 100 but it's like a
20 in the line of credit yeah and about
you know 50 like about 50 from your
favorite place so far so
yeah i got i got that one and then we
bought another house a four family for
about four
for half a million but we got it down to
like 450 we put some money into it we
put about 40 into it what's it worth
today it's probably 6.50 and what do you
owe on that total
on it right now
450.
okay so i got it 850 okay there it is
all right
and then
we have about
uh my wife's got a car
23 000 in car and about 6 000 on credit
cards no student loans we paid all that
off
and
yeah okay
why are you calling us how can we help
um now here's the thing the my
the property that doesn't have any debt
on it right
i need to pull money off that property
to get rid of the interest rate on
the debt that i took out the re to
renovate it right yeah why are you
calling us
to see what do you want to do
how could you what's the best way to
structure it and to see what your
recommendation is
okay
um
i started buying real estate when i was
22 by the time i was 26 i owned four
million dollars worth and i had a
about a three million dollar debt on it
so i had a million dollars worth of
equity in the real estate
starting from nothing
um
what you're doing sounds very stressful
to me it does not sound like there's any
peace in your voice
yeah we try to figure it out yourself
structure everything so yeah i think you
i think you play the edges on everything
don't you
oh no
three or four times on the shell still
trying to hide it just in this
conversation
yeah you're man um
we're not in the debt restructuring
business we're in the debt payoff
business and it doesn't sound like
you're at a point where you want to
become completely debt free or that
you're willing to do what it takes to
get there yeah the the question you're
asking out and the the answers we're
going to give
are all around the same issue the issue
is okay you're 33 when you're 43 what
moves are going to make you the best off
okay the best off financially and have
the best quality of life with four
little kids and both of you working big
uh high-stress jobs uh and everything so
i'm going to get rid of one of these
properties and a whole bunch of not if
not all of this debt in the process
because i think that's going to add an
amazing amount of peace to your life a
you cut your
uh number of tenants in half
b you got rid of almost if not all of
your debt so 400 and 166 pays off the
hunt you get rid of everything but the
debt on the rental your you pay off your
mortgage your car your credit cards and
the hundred thousand it's owed you sell
the 400 000 property that's probably
what i'm gonna do because that will take
me because the peace
and the calm steady movement rather than
the flailing about will cause you to
build more wealth over time
and you you've been you've been just
kind of pushing the edges on this maybe
you don't realize you are but it uh and
if you don't realize you are that's even
more of a problem because i i know this
guy because i was him i mean i i they
some about the real estate business they
take the risk meter out of your heart
and they put it on table and hit it with
a hammer and break it so you no longer
can measure risk and you don't you don't
perceive that all of this is risk you
just see returns you go
well the renters are paying it off no
they're not the renters don't pay their
bill half the time you got a problem all
the time with that
and so
it's just an issue so no i um
you know i'm going to move you backward
what feels like backward to you but set
you into a real calm place
let's visit where you are at that point
okay the probably the 650 with the 450
loan is cash flowing
it's probably cash flowing a little not
a lot
but you got zero debt then no house
payment
no car payment no hundred thousand
dollar unsecured hanging out there at a
high interest rate
and you only got a couple tenants
and you make 275 000 a year
and you're 33 years old that's a much
better place than where you are today
brother
to be that's a much more solid platform
to launch into
the future
we don't find
alan very many people in our millionaire
study that borrowed their way into
becoming millionaires using the system
you're using or that i used when i went
broke
um
most people the vast majority of
millionaires do not do that to become
millionaires and so
that data is real
it's not a theory and it's not a well
what about the new year
there's no arguing with the actual data
most people dave especially young guys
they want to get into real estate
investing and our advice is to have a
paid for property for yourself first
then do all of your real estate
investing in cash
to them it sounds insane
why do we say that
because
the shortest distance to wealth is
always no debt
it's the shortest fastest route
and it's not just i made that up i mean
it's in the bible the borrower's slave
to the lender oh also
all the data with the ten thousand
millionaires that we've studied oh also
if you just walk around and talk to rich
people they're not gonna tell you you
know i did it with bitcoin you know i
did i got this big hit i bought llamas
i opened a llama farm they were big one
time there was a big rich quick thing on
llama llama farms wow and i bought
beanie babies they don't tell you that
and they don't say i did nothing down
real estate because i got to tell you
man i
i knew probably
100 people doing nothing down real
estate in the 80s
100 of them are out of the business wow
or
they paid off everything and got out of
the debt business one of the two i
actually know one guy that he he cashed
out of about three quarters of his
portfolio ended up with 25 as many
properties
and they were all debt free that's he
got everything he got tired of he got
tired of living on the edge most people
go well that's stupid dave you're losing
out on all the cash flow of the
properties well the thing is in the in
when they're leveraged they don't cash
flow that much
you know that 450 over 650 he's not
making much money their margins on that
you have after you have vacancy uh you
have loss
you know credit loss meaning they don't
pay the bill they go into bankruptcy you
have a heat and air unit go out you have
a roof leak
um you know you pay your taxes
you pay you know and by the time you
finish all that he's not making much
cash flow on that
he's not getting rich off that house now
the value may be shooting up but the
actual cash on cash there's not much
there
so this idea that somehow you're going
to like
just buy a house and the money just
starts coming in no it really doesn't if
you leverage it up to your eyeballs so
it's all about delayed gratification
yeah it's go a little slower or go a lot
slower which in the end of the story
ends up being faster he who hastens to
be rich will not go unpunished there it
is again film
george campbell ramsey personality in
the booth is austin ben zack andrew and
of course james i am dave ramsey and
we'll be back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five starting off this
hour's josh in dallas texas hey josh how
are you
good how are you doing dave better than
we deserve brother how can we help
yes uh i'm a federal employee and i
heard you talking to another controller
not too long ago about tsp and i was
wondering if you could be given too much
of the tsp that could reduce your income
at the same time
i don't know if that was possible
if you could put too much into the tsp
yeah if your income
correct oh you're talking about taxable
income so you were using
yeah aren't they offering a roth tsp now
yes we do have our tsp i'm on the
traditional tsp as well yeah i'm trying
to do a budget i did fpu
about seven years ago with my life
but we kind of gotten out of control
lately and
i'm sitting there trying to figure out
where's all my money going i don't know
if it's gas and
inflation mortgage so i'm just trying to
get a control of my money and budgeting
but i don't know if you could go to us
uh too much in the csp
well or even taxes yeah
uh we recommend a roth more than a
traditional
and a match more than a roth and uh some
tsp has match most does not
and uh so i would i would i wouldn't
move the stuff that's in traditional
over but i would from this point forward
make my contributions into the wrath
and
[Music]
but all of that would be after you're
out of debt and have an emergency fund
is that right would you yeah that's
where i'm at i'm kind of in debt um
but i was wondering if i could if i
should stop doing tsp you're in debt
yeah and what kind of debt have you got
credit card and then used car payment
what's the total amount of the debt
let's see five on the credit card
and about
20 on the car
used car
okay well
how long would it take to pay off all
this debt right now if you got intense
about it
maybe
three months
okay what's your household income well i
actually i just say on the credit card
about three months and then the car
maybe another year ah
what's your household income
um
before taxes in 94. uh so about five
thousand a month
um
wife is a stay-at-home mom
okay so
all right well josh we we have figured
out that the shortest
path
the quickest path the most sure path to
wealth is to
get control of your largest wealth
building tool which is your income
meaning to get debt paid off before we
start investing
and so
we tell folks to work a plan called the
baby steps
and uh baby step one is you stop all
investing temporarily and have a
thousand dollars in the bank how much do
you have in savings is not retirement
uh
savings we do have an emergency fund how
am i uh
900 and i'm getting close to doing a
thousand on an emergency fund so you've
kind of heard about this then yes yes we
did fbu a while back and now we're
trying to get back into it but we gave
away our books and everything okay well
we're going to put you back through it
because we want you to get we want you
didn't pass the first time
right
right
so uh
so
you know
we're going to do the baby steps which
means we're going to temporarily stop
retirement we're going to tighten this
budget down we're not doing anything
until we get these 25 000 paid off and i
think you can do it probably a little
faster than you're thinking
uh you probably are you know and should
be able to do it in a year okay from
today 100 done and then when you're out
of debt everything but the house that's
going to feel pretty good then we're
going to take a thousand dollar account
build it up to three to six months of
expenses
then we'll start the tsp back up in the
roth
okay
josh i know it hurts to pause that
investing you're excited about building
wealth but the truth is
when you pause investing it's going to
accelerate the debt payoff and when you
accelerate the debt payoff you can then
accelerate the investing because a lot
of people are scraping by trying to
throw you know percentages at the
investment but the truth is instead of
putting five percent in and you're
hoping to get to 10 you're going to be
able to put 15 when you don't owe anyone
anything and so that's what we want for
you and that's what i did and man it's a
game changer
so hang on uh we're gonna have austin
pick up and get you signed up for
financial peace university again
uh as our gift
and that includes the every dollar uh
premium version it's all a part of
ramsey plus we'll give you a one-year
subscription to all of it and you can go
right back through the lessons we're
getting ready to launch brand new
financial peace university lessons and
one of the lessons folks
you'll be seeing in about about a couple
weeks from now uh features dr john
deloney and george campbell talking
about the psychology of marketing
and how that impacts your spending and
uh it's a brand new lesson that we've
never had in fpu and it's really good
it's really good i was going through the
i was playing ceo and going through the
screening it going through and screening
all of these the other day and i'm like
you know what these this is the best
financial piece university lessons we've
ever done wow i've probably done 10 15
shoots over the years uh different
versions of it you know on the video and
and then on the dvd and then of course
online now
and um
we've added and changed and twisted and
learned to teach the curriculum and
shortened it and being more direct more
concise more to the point and it's i
gotta tell you george i mean you rachel
deloney uh it's really really good it's
uh it's the new financial peace
university lessons that will just be
starting here in a couple of weeks
you're you guys are gonna want to be in
ramsey plus and get that going because
it's they're they're strong and if
you've got friends or relatives that
have never been through it and you buy
them uh you know you buy them a one-year
membership to financial piece and and
all that they'll get these new lessons
and
um
you know where i was in a meeting last
night with a bunch of the leadership
team there they got all kinds of plans
for the online experience with the
workbook being online and all that oh
yeah you know
stuff on the whiteboard that's beautiful
it's really that's awesome well you know
financial peace university is the thing
that changed my life when i started
working here and so it's an honor to be
in it i mean i'm just pinching myself
going oh my gosh it's amazing i get to
be in this and help create that life
change that i experienced yeah and
you're good i mean you really did a good
job that means a lot yeah
and the uh the production values the
staging and the process the people that
our guys just know our team's amazing
they make us look good they never get
out of the park baby check it out
yeah you can do that and the way the
thing's set up now guys it's pretty easy
to gift it uh to a friend or a real yeah
we got our own website for that
yeah ramsay solutions.com gift yeah
that's pretty cool and uh you know you
can set it up easy and
uh
you know just like we just gave it to
him you know it's it's a lot of you i
mean like 10 million people been through
it that's amazing well then your name
doesn't have to be a cuss word instead
of talking about dave you just go hey
how about this i'll gift you ramsay plus
go watch the videos done
that's a lot of cussing i like that
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today laura's in st louis hey
laura what's up
hey hi dave and george thank you for
taking my call and thank you for what
you do i actually became a financial
advisor because of you wow very cool
honored thank you yeah thanks and i got
my cfp good for you i'll be the best i
can
so i started from scratch and built a
nice business
however i'm in an area that is kind of
overrun by men and i am the one that
they bully
so i've made an offer with another firm
how do you make that decision and do you
think my clients will follow because the
the idea of starting over scares me
sounds to me like you've already made
the decision
yeah but
yeah it's just um i'm going to jump
off of this diving board
and i know i'm not going to get hurt but
i've never done it before and so it
still scares me
right but i'm going to jump
that's really what you just said
you're not going to stay there
you have too much self-respect to stay
in a situation that you just described
to me
my fear is that the clients won't follow
because i can't contact them for a year
your fear of that does not supersede
your fear of staying in this toxic
situation
true so you're leaving
so
build an emergency fund before i leave
because i'll be starting over with no
salary you're single
no
you're broke
no okay
so why do you have to do all that you're
all right
you're not going to go hungry
and here's the thing
okay
um
you built this book of business it did
not come because of one of the bullies
right
right
so why in the world would they stay with
the bully they came to you in the first
place
true
have you i mean from a from a practical
standpoint now do they have any kind of
a legal hold on that book
yes
oh
so what happens if your client walks in
and says i want i'm going to leave and
i'm going to nothing go to laura nothing
but you can't you can't solicit them
yes
okay
so you've got a non-solicitation when
you leave but if they come to you
without you reaching out to them that's
okay
yes
okay so you can't proactively
how often do you usually have contact
with them
with my top 100
at least quarterly
okay
so kind of walk it through with me what
do you think will happen when top 100
calls in because you haven't called them
because you're not allowed to
and they say oh laura left
i would imagine they would ask where i
went
will they tell you tell them
um they have to by law send that a
letter oh being where i went
in advance
yes well as soon as i put in my
resignation when i leave the firm then
they have to send out a letter seeing
where i went
and the new firm is going to do all
sorts of advertising okay
oh this is sounds like free marketing to
me they're sending out a letter no
brainer marketing your new company
listen you're going to get 60 or 80 of
them
because you're you're a relationship
person you built relationships with them
and trust with them they work with you
for a reason
and it's because you're laura it's not
just because you know stuff
that's what someone else said i just
wanted to hear it from you
well i mean you and i both know the cfp
world okay
yes and uh
there are cfps that are relational
they they to the point that
uh you will end up working with some of
these people's grandkids
over the decades
um and then there are cfps that are
certified financial pharisees
that's true too and they're they're
they're legalistic
maniacs
and all they are is super nerds and they
have the relationship skills of a dead
doorknob
right
right and that i mean that's the
business that you're in and and
you know so you got no competition
that's why the dave ramsey thing's such
a big deal because i was the first guy
who said money stuff out loud in a way
that wasn't so nerdy and talking down to
people like they were all idiots i go
hey that's stupid but i'm stupid too
i don't go like you're stupid and i'm
smart
you know
and so that that's the world you're
gonna do fine
you're gonna do fine how long it take
you to build this book of business
eight years oh you're gonna be fine
how old are you
51.
51
yes oh you're almost dead you're not
going to make
that's my it dave you're 10 years older
than me
[Laughter]
and i learned about you in my 30s you're
just getting started
that was an underhand pitch kiddo
you're going to be amazing dave's about
to hit his midlife crisis so what do you
do what do you think joe what do you
think the percentages will follow her
you know the business too yeah i would
say 50 of the clients are going to jump
over because they don't want to deal
with whoever the new guy is i'd say it's
more than that i mean wouldn't you jump
i mean yeah you don't go to a company
our smart investor pros don't really i
just did this with my barber i like my
barber i don't care about where he works
i just want to follow my barber because
i thought about the problem i have
george so you don't have to deal with
that david the one thing i have on you
is haters right that's uh you you're
definitely much better
and so but it's the same concept yeah i
trust my barber we have a relationship i
don't i tried the other guys it didn't
work out with him so i moved with him to
his new business that's that is a good
example i mean
and you know
your doctor i just my doctor just
changed he changed his hospital i didn't
go back to the goobs that he used to
work with
i went when he i went with the guy with
the new goobs that he moved to you know
i mean
and it's a freaking doctor i don't i
don't need to start over with this guy
yeah it's not i don't need to uh it's
too much trouble too much medical
history oh yeah because i don't have no
i have no medical history that's the
point i'm sure you go to the doctor like
once every eight years
at least you don't strike medical type
at least has a sniffle and decides to go
see the doctor i he he the only reason
he knows me is we're just personal
friends outside of work so
unless dave's on a stretcher
the point though is not that the point
is she's gonna do fabulous because you
can just tell talking to her
she i mean i trust her just talking to
her for a minute yeah she the way she
carries herself her vernacular her voice
tone her cadence she's a she's you've
since
uh a solid
person of integrity
that is not in a hurry and not greedy
she's actually worried about them
not just her that's a unicorn in the
financial planning world they're out
there i mean they're smart our smart
investor pros fall in that category
they're those kinds of people but the
rest of them i mean are not not
everybody that's not smart vista pro but
i mean there's too many people in the
business that are all about super
nerding
um or they're uh
they just get caught up in the nuances
of stuff but she's gonna do great i i
think i think you're wrong george i
think it's 75
so laura you call us back call us back
in six months and tell us who won the
bet george's george's got his money on
50. i got my money on 75.
so i play conservative i know i'm not
like rachel i'm i'm a big lara fan so
that's fair you know i think this is
where it's going all right this is good
stuff uh sylvana is with us in uh new
york city is it sylvaina is that correct
silvana i apologize how can i help
hi so i am a current college student um
my second year um i just
transferred last year from a community
college so this is probably my first
year at a four-year college
um i still have like
about two and a half more years to go
to finish my degree in computer
engineering
um
problem arises that i don't qualify for
any financial aid whatsoever under
my parents are divorced so under my mom
nothing because she makes way too much
money but scholarships and work
you qualify for jobs and you qualify for
scholarships
um
scholarships
how many have you applied for
i've lost count
i haven't even kept track i've applied
for everything okay you should have
applied for 200 by now
not 20.
and 20 is the number that you've
actually applied for
you have to go for a whole bunch of them
we have christina ellis ramsey
personality she got a half a million
dollars in scholarships a half a million
dollars you don't need that much
so scholarships oh and by the way kiddo
lots of people out there begging for
people to work right now you can make
serious money in new york city right now
because nobody's working
go to work
and work your butt off and you can get
through school i promise you keep your
expenses down and do it
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host we invite you to stop by ramsay
solutions if you're in the nashville
area we have a big visitor center and we
do the show on the glass and so you can
watch the zoo animals inside the glass
doing our thing and uh we're here for
three hours every afternoon from one to
four central time there's free coffee
and free cookies and it all smells good
and tastes good and nice people around
there's usually 50 to 200 folks hanging
out out here and on the lobby in the
lobby on the debt free stage colin and
julie are joining us hey guys how are
you hey hey dave how are you where do
you guys live gainesville georgia ah the
swamp
all right very cool well welcome to
nashville good to have you how much debt
have you paid off
136 and 41 months
way to go
and your range of income during that
time
118 to 138 yep cool what do you guys do
for a living
i'm an engineer and collin's a realtor
ah very good very good how long y'all
been married
three years
so you started this journey a little bit
before marriage each of you working on
yours and then
combine incomes and get after it huh
correct all right so all this happened i
guess after college
so what kind of debt was this student
loans or what it's a mortgage you paid
off your house
oh my gosh and you've been married three
years how old are you guys i'm 31 and
she's 29. oh my
god awesome you're so weird
way to go 31-29 so what's this house
worth mr realtor right now we could
probably hawk it for 3 30 if we wanted
to but we're uh we're renovating so
not yet
that is amazing
wow all right tell me how you become a
genius this early in life what happened
what's the deal well julie's the genius
uh i'm just
i'm just the voice behind everything but
she's she's the brains behind the
operation and uh we
started the journey
in 2018 we bought our home in 2017 but
we were davish and then we were both
working second shift and had no social
life so we're like well what are we
gonna put this money towards
so uh we just started the journey and i
decided to get after a goal we're very
goal-oriented yeah i guess so well you
got two great careers and
very cool when you don't have a social
life you can pay off the house that's
there it is
i'm impressed so did you guys start your
marriage off debt-free
well uh so three years into it so we
didn't have any debt and except for the
mortgage but whenever we got married
right yeah just the mortgage that's
amazing so how did you guys uh learn
this whole ramsay stuff
julie was
the one that got us on board i was very
tough to get going at first and then uh
once we started seeing how quickly we
could attack it whenever we have set our
mind to it it was
it was awesome wow
were you a realtor at the time i started
off in logistics and we decided that
wasn't for me and moved to real estate
and
you know first two years you know as the
roller coaster of course yeah and things
have started looking looking great and
uh
so that's
where we're at now oh way to go you guys
you're impressive this is amazing i mean
you did this really fast really early
and just knocked it out house and how
does it feel to not have a payment in
the world pretty weird
yeah changes it changes the way you
handle yourself when you're selling a
piece of real estate it certainly does i
encourage all my clients to knock it out
as soon as they can yeah but i mean you
just when you don't have any payments
you don't have to make the sale right
and so you just think about them you do
the right thing and it ends up you end
up making more sales because you're just
relaxed you're not desperate yeah and
you know i'm put on this earth to serve
people and you know
i don't care about their commission i
just want to help them yeah and and now
you really don't have to
they care about the commission yeah so
what was it like making that final
payment was it anti-climactic or was it
everything you hoped for
a little anticlimactic it took them you
know weeks to send us that
that letter payoff letter yeah but we
did do a mortgage burning party which
nobody knows about anymore and uh we had
a champagne battle in our front yard oh
that's fun
it was colin's dream to put on our scuba
mask and do this this is a great you
gotta go watch on youtube because this
is hilarious oh this is great
is that family gathering around what is
that yeah a lot of family a couple
neighbors and uh but julie definitely
won the champagne battle she uh i
started off strong and she just came in
and just absolutely blasted me in the
face well you're messing with an
engineer i mean come on she had this
figured out i should have known better
yeah that's it
wow so did your family and friends think
you guys are weird but we're on board
we're happy for you yep so our parents
were huge cheerleaders throughout and
you know
a lot of our friends were kind of
scratching their heads and uh
but we knew what we wanted and you know
more than anything we wanted to get that
done so we could renovate the home and
uh and that kind of thing yeah yeah what
are you doing what's the renovation
so right now we're in the middle of the
master bathroom and uh so we just gotta
tile that up now and uh but yeah we're
we're excited and uh we've
just found out we're having a baby we're
doing november
hey
life is great oh man so i gotta i gotta
remodel i got a november sixth date that
i i gotta get everything done bye
now we have a new goal oh
yeah a deadline
way to go you guys life is so good
so one of the things we found in the uh
millionaire study that we did studying
10 000 millionaires the number one
uh
occupation that becomes a millionaires
engineer
and so here we go you're just because
you're process people and you get it you
know and real estate agents that are
goal oriented like this they fall right
in there too so that that's uh non-goal
oriented real estate agents now that's a
different story but yeah yeah well done
you guys we're proud of you what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
appreciate what you have your people and
your things right and also combine your
finances
build
absolutely got to have the same checking
account and yeah everybody's got to be
on board you know transparency and
and we've never been ones to keep up
with the joneses and so that was a
definitely a helping factor you know we
don't spend money if we don't have to
yeah good good for you well done you
guys sharp young couple yeah this is
inspiring i'm seeing a trend here dave
we're gonna see more people in their 20s
and early 30s paying off their homes
which means more millionaires earlier i
think we're stirring up a ruckus georgia
i like this what if we can make the
government irrelevant
that's a goal i can get behind that
i'm with this all you guys are amazing
way to go you guys way to go very good
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure
and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody maybe you'll inspire one of
your buddies to actually follow in your
footsteps you never know when they see
you out in the front yard of scuba mess
and champagne they want to know what's
going on yeah so that's good stuff and
also we're going to send you a our give
you a gift card for financial peace
university and the every dollar premium
and a ramsey plus subscription for a
year and all of that tied in and you can
give that to somebody and get them
started or you guys can go through it as
well and good stuff very good stuff and
congratulations on the new baby on the
way that's just awesome
life is good very very cool good for you
guys colin and julie gainesville georgia
29 31 years old they have a 330 000
house that is paid for
136 000 in debt paid off in 41 months
making 118 to 138 hadn't even been
married 41 months i've been working on
it excellent count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three three two one
[Applause]
wow
our millionaire study found the average
millionaire pays off their home in 11
years
and so these folks right here above
average
did it in 31 months 41 months wow yeah
yeah that's um
here's the thing
if you're out there and you're stumbling
on this show for the first time or the
sixth time
there's a reason we do this these are
actual real people we don't tell them
what to say
um the matter of fact they flew or drove
to nashville from florida
to stand on the stage to have that
moment that milestone and scream
in front of you know 22 million people
on podcast radio and youtube
and have a moment there because they
wanted to inspire you
they want you to know you can do it
and you know what
you can do it
and if you think you can or you think
you can't
you're right
that's what henry ford said and i think
he was onto something
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 19 23 the
fear of the lord leads to life then one
rests content
untouched by trouble
albert einstein says whoever is careless
with the truth in small matters cannot
be trusted
in important affairs
no doubt about it open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
paul is with us in jackson mississippi
hey paul how are you
doing all right man how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
well i've i've come into a
a predicament here that um a lot of
people don't don't get the chance to do
um here in about four months i'm going
to be receiving a check for about 1.2
million dollars wow um how's that
where'd that come
um a
[Music]
a land deal
okay so you you had a piece of land that
you sold and it's gonna you're gonna net
you 1.2 million
well actually it's sort of like a
finder's fee i found some land took it
to a developer
it was worth a lot of money um and he's
going to turn it around
so that's going to be my percentage of
the profit wow very nice okay
i hate it when that happens good job
if you find any more let me know
absolutely okay how can we help but yeah
um i'm i'm 27 um i have about 50 000 in
debt
um
and taking in this kind of money
it's great but it's also kind of scary
because i don't know what to
do well that's a lot of wisdom
it's why it's wise to be scared if you
were
strutting around acting like you knew
what to do and you'd never done it
before that would be the first sign you
were going to lose the money so um
really good really good position to take
a healthy kind of fear not not toxic
fear not being
anxiety ridden or something but uh just
going ah this scares me a little bit
like this is a really powerful car and
i'm not that great a driver yet
right yeah
cool
so
should should i should i
i don't own a home right now um i'm
renting
should i
should i take
um
i don't know 200 000 and put it down on
a house
or should i mean
should i reinvest this money or you know
and i have i have a day job as well all
this
side income that i have is is working
from
4 30 to 10 o'clock at night and on
saturdays and sundays wow not a bad side
hustle
yes i know i've always been really
driven
um and i'm so what do you make a year on
your day job
70 000 okay and you're used to living on
that
oh yes okay all right well you can do a
lot of different things paul um i'll
give you a couple of things that uh
first let me throw some just basic ideas
at you and then i'll throw some
conceptual ideas at you as well okay
basic idea is um write check pay off the
debt
okay
okay you said you had 50 000 in debt
right
yes sir okay so you write a check and
you pay off the debt that's thing one
thing two is you need to sit down with
attack a good tax pro
and calculate what the taxes are gonna
be on this and then just set that aside
and pretend like it's not yours because
it's not yours
you're gonna get in a pinch if you start
screwing around with a portion of this
that is taxes so just set aside an
account over there and be ready for next
april when it rolls around
uh and hold on the money long as you can
hold on to it but just put it in a money
market account and pretend like you
don't own it anymore
and that's gonna be substantial amount
of money
i figured it would be around 250 yeah i
think probably 30. i think it's probably
300. yeah but sit down with your tax pro
and calculate it exactly and set that
aside okay
and then that tells you what you got to
work with okay so let's call it 300 and
then let's uh call the other 50 and that
gets us down to 850.
okay correct um and yeah what would you
if you were going to buy a home do you
want a house
uh you know not necessarily um not not
in the market that it is right now i
don't want to pay
you know i don't want to pay 300 000 for
a house that's worth 170. uh honey it's
worth 300. it's not worth 175.
okay it's not coming back down
okay
the real estate prices have retreated in
the history of the united states never
okay long term well that makes me a
little bit more comfortable i mean we
had one retreat in the 30s and it came
back up we had another retreat in the 08
and it came back up and those are the
only two times it ever went backwards
and it came back up uh and so we're not
we're not going to see a retreat in as a
result of this mess we're in right now
but we are going to see a slowing in
growth so but you're a single 27 year
old guy you may not want to screw with a
house you may want to get you a nice
condo or you want to mess with stuff
right i don't know what your living
situation is but i would go pay cash for
a
residence okay whatever that is and so
let's call that 300. that still leaves
you 550 laying around
what are you driving what are you
driving
um i've got a
2018 f-250 okay okay that's where all my
dad is okay oh that's that's the truck
okay should pay off the truck keep the
truck that's a great car keep it okay
what's your solution well beyond that i
mean you can always park extra money in
a high-yield savings account and use it
towards your next goal so i love the
idea of getting a reasonable residence
let's pay off all the debt let's put
let's get our emergency fund in place so
set aside maybe you know 20 30k over
here for that and beyond that look at
what your next goals are maybe you want
to do real estate investing and you want
to pay cash for that maybe you want to
go on some vacations
maybe you want to set it aside because
you don't know what's going to happen in
the next five years maybe you meet
someone you get married and so i like
the idea of parking a lot of this aside
once we have our house paid for
yeah nothing wrong with that at all
here's the thing if you want to deal
with the fear like sometimes i talk to
someone that's inherited two million
dollars or something and they're like i
don't know what to do i don't know
anything about money
and so uh you know we put them through
financial peace university immediately
which we're gonna do for you okay i'm
gonna pay for you to go through it
because i want you to get the basics on
handling money down and then you kind of
build yourself a little board of
directors for this million dollar
business
and the board of directors is a good
insurance agent
a good estate planning attorney helps
you get a will in place
a good tax tax professional in your
corner
uh sounds like you already know a lot
about real estate uh but you may you
know if you want to put a real estate
person in your corner that's fine but
you put some experts around you that
will teach you different things that you
need to know
uh to be able to do things that you
don't know how to do
um mike for instance my estate plan is
very complicated um there's no possible
way i could have invented with my
knowledge base my estate plan so i have
paid an estate planning lawyer a lot of
money
to keep my family from having to pay
tens of millions of dollars in taxes
after i die
because they tax you twice in the u.s
now because if you're rich you must be
evil and you should be punished
so um
but the uh you know that's an example i
don't do my own taxes
uh and i i could probably muddle through
but i probably miss some stuff i don't
pull my own teeth either so
um you know that that's the thing you're
dealing with so you know you kind of get
some advisors around you so that you've
got and you don't have to pay them
anything they're just there and you
develop a relationship and get maybe a
good maybe meet with one of the smart
investor pros about investing in mutual
funds i you may want to take that half
million and you may be a real estate guy
that wants to do some deals
and just do them all with cash
and you can't mess them up if you're
doing them with cash
uh because there's i've never seen a
single piece of real estate in my life
go to zero
uh and you know it's not it doesn't it's
not bitcoin i mean it can't go to zero
so uh you know if you want to buy a
piece of land and you want to fool with
it flip it over you want to buy property
and flip it
or you want to buy some properties that
create income that's all okay
good news about jackson mississippi it
is a reasonable real estate market uh
much more so than a lot of areas of the
country so
um a lot of stuff you can do there you
got a lot of options congratulations sir
it's amazing very proud i want this to
set him up for the future he's 27. and
if he manages this money well he's gonna
be able to retire early do whatever he
wants to do well i mean if you invest a
half a million dollars and you made 10
off that's 50 000 a year that's not bad
you know and you got taxes on that and
other stuff and it won't be 10 of your
every year but you make 10 averages but
he can about replace his income if he
investors get real close and if you left
it alone
you know it'll double every seven years
so in seven years he's 27 when he's 34
if you know he'd have a million
and uh so when he's 41 he'd have 2
million wow
and just just off of that that's
incredible that's you know something to
think about yeah but yeah that that but
again that's investing it in mutual
funds leaving it alone but if you're
going to fuel real estate you can
probably make more than that but you got
more hassle and expertise involved
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you